a name is for room peter i am the
manager of the supermarket in
woluwe-saint-
lambrechts- they also look there have a
larger pack of people customers who actually come
to our store
think mainly because we are afraid
of going to a large supermarket we
see  the large masses go and think
they are comfortable with us there given the
fewer customers and less number of people
on a certain area
first of all so it is important that the
people respect the rules
no matter how difficult it is and
certainly with it  nice weather everyone wants
to come outside and so
ideas see his family my greatest
wish louisa everyone stays healthy wife
and and
to family and so that everyone still
follows drees and no matter how long that
will take it
difficult that it is followed between the
most important rules
I bring it is important when people
come to shop with us that they still
follow the rains so that they keep their
distance from each other  ar
corner of our own staff because
we stand was in the morning or evening
anyway in the first line actually and I
would like to go to my personal sun
stays not only for you but also for
me all together we are stronger against
crowns